Speaker 1: There is a new report, an extremely
disturbing report which found that at least
eight Republicans who were at the January
6th rally have been elected to office.
Now these are not necessarily people who were
participating in the riot, but these are folks
who were at the rally on January 6th Huffington
Post article.
At least eight Republicans who were elected
at the rally just got elected to office, and
even more attendees of the rally that turned
into the riot will likely be on the ballot
in 2022.
Although most have claimed they didn't breach
the U.S. Capitol on that day, all were participants
in the demonstration leading up to the attack.
Standing alongside extremists to take part
in the finale of a months long anti-democratic
campaign to falsely claim that then-President
Donald Trump didn't really lose 2020, their
victories on Tuesday are a possible sign of
things to come.
HuffPost previously identified 57 state and
local Republican officials who attended the
rally, many of whom will be up for reelection
and likely will win next year.
That these candidates enjoy the support of
the wider Republican Party and are winning
elections does not bode well for American
democracy.
That's an understatement, showing that one
of the country's major political parties.
Despite some initial gestures at being horrified
by the events of Jan. six, is almost completely
unrepentant over its role in fomenting the
historic attack on the Capitol.
And why wouldn't they?
There have barely been consequences, as I
said before, not only barely consequences
for the perpetrators, many of their cases
still pending, but no real consequences for
the insiders, and some of them are getting
rewarded by getting elected.
Among the Jan. six attendees who won office
on Tuesday were two Republicans reelected
to the Virginia House of Delegates Dave Lerach
and John Maguire.
Marie Mar, a restaurant owner who bragged
about her attendance at the Stop the Steal
rally and who in a since deleted Facebook
post, warned of a coming civil war in which
she would be willing to fight and die for
both her family and small businesses also
want a seat in the Virginia House of Delegates
on Tuesday.
In city councils across the country, rally
attendee Natalie Jiang Gula won a seat in
Nampa, Idaho.
Christine Eade, who didn't go into the Capitol
and later blamed the violence on Antifa, won
a seat in Watchung New Jersey.
Charles Asperger also won a seat on the Town
Council of Mansfield, Connecticut.
Susan Solloway organized transportation to
the rally won reelection to the Hunterdon
County, New Jersey board of directors in Braintree,
Massachusetts.
A former high school teacher who resigned
his position after local activists sent a
photo of him outside the Capitol won a seat
on the local school committee.
It goes on and on and on.
This is a really backwards time now, just
an example of someone elected to give you
a sense of the caliber of these people.
This is not someone, but from the rally.
This is just an example of a Republican that
voters liked enough to elect.
This is New Jersey truck driver Edward Durr,
who was just elected a Republican state senator,
and when he was asked, Well, what are you
going to do in Trenton?
He said, I don't really know.
I don't.
I have no idea this.
This is who is now in a position of power.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Chose to sit back and do nothing.
Speaker 3: And what's the first thing you're
going to do when you get to the Capitol in
Trenton?
Speaker 2: I really don't know that's that's
the key factor, I don't know what I don't
know,
Speaker 1: that is the key factor.
Speaker 2: We'll learn what I need to know
and I'm going to guarantee you one thing.
Yeah, I will be the voice and people will
hear me because if there's one thing people
will learn about me, I got a big mouth and
I don't show up when I want to be heard.
Speaker 1: I'm going to be heard.
This is not a lot.
The host is laughing.
This is horrifying, guys.
Speaker 2: I will.
Go ahead, go ahead.
Now you go ahead, finish your thought.
Oh my God.
I was just going to say that I will be that
voice for the people because
Speaker 1: I chose to sit down, man.
I wasn't kidding yesterday with my 30 rant,
and the rant sort of was.
This week's elections might set the tone for
some major Republican wins in 2022, which
could include taking control back of the House
and Senate.
I've already said 2024 with Biden or Harris
as the Democratic nominees.
It's looking dubious to me.
You could see Republicans take the House and
Senate in twenty two.
And the White House in 24 and then in twenty
six.
Democrats are really going to be up against
the wall, and Republicans will have continued
damaging the environment in the country.
It could be a very tough eight to 10 years
for this country.
And again, I said this on a stream.
There are some people who are mad and some
people who agreed.
In many blue states, things are going to be
fine.
This is not blue state elitism and me saying,
I don't have to worry because I live in blue
states.
It's an empirical reality that if you look
at the Human Development Index of Massachusetts,
it's the same as Norway.
Quality of life is like Norway.
Connecticut has the HDI ranking of Switzerland,
Minnesota, New Hampshire, Connecticut.
They have the Human Development Index ranking
of Germany and Hong Kong.
New York is equivalent to Australia and the
Netherlands.
In lots of those places, many things are going
to be mostly fine, but stuff like pollution
and so many others that cross state lines
are going to be really bad everywhere.
And I still care about people in red states.
Do that have the equivalent, you know, standard
of living of of much poorer countries, so
could be ugly for a long time.
And the last 96 hours aren't pointing in a
great direction.
Make sure you're following us on Instagram
at David Pakman show we'll be back right after
this short break